c'est en 2018 que clara luciani a fait
une entrée fracassante dans le paysage
musical français
avec son titre la grenade la jeune femme
est devenue incontournable
un titre certifié disque de platine et
qui s'est retrouvé numéro un des ventes
pendant de nombreuses semaines
[Musique]
à
la chanteuse était l'invitée de cette a8
l'occasion de revenir sur son succès
mais aussi de lever le voile sur des
parties plus intimes de sa vie elle a
par exemple évoqué le harcèlement
scolaire dont elle a été victime plus
jeune je me souviens des punaises sur ma
chaise un jour en rentrant un don classe
et puis des cartouches d'encre découper
ainsi son échelle encore la chanteuse
est également revenu sur une rumeur
persistante autour de son état de santé
sur scène de nombreuses personnes ont
remarqué qu'elle était parfois victimes
de tremblements si certains ont pensé
qu'elle avait bu ou qu'elles étaient
drogués la jeune femme a expliqué que la
raison était tout autre il est exagéré
quand je suis sur scène ma maman a le
même problème de tremblements et je sais
pas quelle trempe de plus en plus des
confidences qui nous permettent de mieux
connaître cet artiste jusque là plutôt
discrète
son sein
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'arras luciani est donc revenu
sur son plus grand complexe
vous allez voir c'est quelque chose qui
la fait vraiment il a vraiment fait
souffrir à l'adolescence vous est-ce que
vous avez des complexes à l'adolescente
regardez vous avez vous lire juste avant
garde ouais j'ai l'impression que
finalement cette taille a tué mon
enfance quand j'ai été moquée et très
longtemps je mets la géante
quel temps il fait là haut je me
souviens des punaises sur ma chaise un
jour en rentrant en classe et puis des
cartouches d'encre découper ainsi sur la
chaise encore une forme de harcèlement
way aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'on peut
le dire j'ai très vite compris que voilà
ma voix grave ou où ma taille j'allais
devoir les utiliser en fait comme une
force et comme une signature
alors elle mesurait un mètre 76 à 11 ans
graff et elles mesurent aujourd'hui 1 m
82 elle est magnifique on l'a vu très
très belle vraiment très très très jolie
ou es ce que vous avez des complexes
oui j'irai dit c'était pareil maman a
oui mesurer combien déjà gg 1 m 82 ans
5e paraguay effectivement hibernent là
bas c'est un enfer et je connais ça
normalement quand tu arrives tu amènes
est amène sérieux et amène la photo de
gaza des parents il faut aussi qu'ils
soient pauvres est toujours doit pas et
comme la meuf la plus grande de là il ya
toujours une meuf qui est très grande
joie car elle est toujours à côté de la
prof sur le côté dans son côté gauche
par lé commerce
elle met des jupes longues mon frère
normalement c'est stéphanie gravier ou
qu on va muscler
un mec 89 à la drague c'est un truc de
ouf ça veut dire elle est ce qu il était
comme un drogué par des garçons qui sont
beaucoup partagé nom vous dit pas parce
que vous êtes totalement jeune et
immature et la houlala ce que ce que
j'aime chez clara luciani c'est que là
où on voit maintenant qu'elle est
qu'elle est elle est passée outre elle a
totalement assumé c'est que maintenant
elle mets des talons alors mon truc
c'est quand je mettais des talons quand
j'ai compris que je vais mettre des
talons je les deux mètres 22e je me suis
dit là c'est mon talent et a passé le
cap en face c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bien compris que c'était quoi votre
complexe
moi j'ai un complexe de supériorité par
rapport à jean michel plus je le
fréquente plus je me trouve intelligent
bas en comparaison
bah je comprends c'est certain mais
c'est super dur vous avez accompli alors
que j'étais en pension très vite avait
14 ans et complet déjà jeune j'étais
très très très minces mettait deux
t-shirts blancs sur deux pourrait
s'étoffer 58 km 85 et du coup en pension
comme avait beaucoup de gens comme vous
et inculte et violent
[Rires]
l'ambition c'est op et c'est quoi cette
attaque gratuite qui me gros pouce mais
c'est parce que je pense que ce chalet
marre parce que je me faisais agressé
celle là puisque paraît du coup je vous
ai laissé c'est pas beau ça avait du jus
comme pension du coup je faisais les
devoirs de 2,3 comme vous de trois
molosses et georges les devoirs et eu du
coup me protéger non mais si à la
cantine dans les vestiaires partout
parce que sinon je rongeais et rappellé
web alors ça c'est horrible je rigole
pas avec ça mais c'est vrai il avait été
bien bonnes gens qui nous regardent si
c'est non mais c'est vrai mais le
contexte était tout maigrichon mais
est-ce que je peux avoir un tout petit
coup de gueule lorsque vous entendre une
bourgade oui je suis fan et maintenant
mais c'est pas sûr elle sait pas dire
que vu ici à quelque chose qu'il ya un
petit peu agaçant quand vous regardez
maintenant c'est horrible mais cette
espèce de mer se répand de toutes les
vedettes tous les deux jours il inc et
non de mes trios zune kettar se laisse
clairement d'une enquête ait lieu dont
on attend ça tout le temps en effet
motivé vous en fera un bouquet et
surtout arrêter de ce mot harcèlement
scolaire pour n'importe quoi on a tous
et emmerdent à l'école le vrai
harcèlement scolaire c'est pas ça c'est
quand ça se termine dans les
catastrophes
tous les gamins on est en mer dès
l'école trop gentil ça m'agace et
aujourd'hui à des choix a dit massa les
colombes avec les réseaux sociaux je
peux dire qu'à sa norme et c'est bien
que la parole se délie un petit peu mais
c'est que toutes ces vedettes maintenant
qu'ils ôtent aucune pudeur et qui se
répand dans permanent de toujours
prendre ça toujours été comme ça y est
question d'un péché non plein de pudeur
et puis elle fait bien sûr elle parle de
ça parce que ça impacter sur sa vie
ah oui aux actes et sur sa vie chère se
mêlent sentimentale on est celle qu on
est un peu mieux la personne et à cesser
sa grève actuelle parle aussi de son
tremblements parce que tous ces frais se
demande pourquoi quand elle chante elle
tremble elle explique c'est avec plus de
noms mais la vôtre critique est
profondément star parce qu'on connaît
rien d'elle mais rire de mystère
ces temps où la vue et on sait pas ce
qu'il fait en ces pauvres je ne veux pas
savoir il faut pas trop maintenant que
ces gens là on sait que soul est de
savoir quel tonnes john pardon dans ses
concerts alors que je lis dans la traite
il a été malade et est très triste mais
qui portait des couches pendant les
concernant
et alors aussi pendant l'émission à la
télé dit elle accueille plantations
comprenez ce que je veux dire vrai je
comprends oui mais je comprends me suis
pas d'accord mais je peux comprendre
mais je suis pas d'accord géraldine non
je dire tu adores johnny tu connais
c'est toute la vie de john avery n'a pas
empêché de l'idolâtrie vous découvert à
sa mort je t'ai jamais vraiment quand
même robben et moi y'a quelqu'un qui on
disait il ya quelques difficultés
il a de douala ii de l'équipe est là
donc non la minute allait dure 20
minutes la barre de la minute allait
toujours l'ami de qu'on vient de vivre
pas pourquoi il faut c'est chiant de
fautes c'est chiant direct parce que
c'est des bêtises on peut pas entendre
ça c'est pourquoi dit il avait un degré
de harcèlement et c'est bon on n'attend
pas que ce soit grave pour déclare
harcèlement si harcèlement scolaire
séances scolaires on se bat contre ça et
que cet art etc
mais si elle veut parler à vous parler
on lui pose la question à réponses sinon
à papa d'elle-même c'est comme toi tu as
tu as parlé de son harcèlement à l'école
je n'ai jamais dit que j'étais maigri
son école elle joue aujourd'hui pas de
panique la région on va vous amener de
la vitamine a
je suis d'accord avec mathieu sur
l'autre sujet merci
il ya un tel déballage de l'ain team
systématique on s'en rend même plus
compte
il ya une époque on faisait pas sachant
malade et la maintenance est devenue la
norme alors on comprends même pas que
quelqu'un vous raconte pas sa vie de
chat pied on va bien sûr demander
maintenant il y avait déjà pas destiné
non c'est tout